and initiate sequencing and memories are
made of this what is this place
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed
at rst we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the US military soldiers like
yourself you're the first who we
successfully managed to bring back but
improved enhance with the technology in
your veins you have an army inside you
that will not only make you stronger you
will heal you instantly porridge
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going I got unfinished
business
I'm gonna find the man who murdered my
wife and killer
it's not good all right sundown
and initiate sequence okay
who is the next target for elimination
these are little food tell me do you
remember anything
do I know you guys I don't think so
I've been manipulating you
what you think is really sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
[Music]
control me for
sure about that
revenge is what makes a man like you
something about men like me
[Music]
is absolutely fantastic
I feel like I just heard this are they
playing some repeat
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it hello I just wanted
you to know this has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world we're headed upriver lagrimas
de cristal for mr. Huron travel come on
about a good time my brother and I are
looking for passage upriver please go
away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends do you believe in curses -
you're gonna beg minutes are back well I
look forward to disappointing you ten
thousand to bring you there alive
dead is 15,000 why should I pay me dead
dad I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
Oh God sorry Frank it's alright strong
form
I get a swing you put the river cruise
and you can't swim
the price just went out
it's instinctive feeling
the force brought together
we're not alone good people will fight
if we lead them
[Music]
people keep telling me they know me
no one does
[Music]
[Applause]
by weight
[Applause]
you're coming together
is your undoing
[Applause]
what are we doing there or Threepio
taking one last look sir but my friends
[Music]
confronting fear the destiny of the Jedi
[Music]
your destiny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Music]
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down through
the enemy planes in last 40 years yet
you can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts he refused to
die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that
it's one of life's mysteries sir
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick you kind
of set it for extinction
maybe so sorry but not today
hello
you're in grave danger get out of there
now open safe house six
welcome to the Townsend agency I run a
covert group of exceptional women you
guys are like lady spies we work outside
the rules in secret together
we exist but we are always watching
oh you are in the presence of angels so
you want to train to be an angel hell
yeah give me my wings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sit down and keep your hands where I can
see them really not supposed to be
touching things in here unless you're
supposed to be touching things again
you're adorable
J is about you flirting with a handsome
nerd
the best part is unticking down
international criminals with you guys
and the day drinking that's what I like
the most
[Music]
so I can just take whatever I want Baro
is that an actual rule
hey time to go to work
oh come on man you could get that buffed
out no you can get that bucked up no
knock-and-talk what the hell happened Oh
hands behind your head right now I got
this I'm gonna penetrate this man's soul
with my heart what watch sir I realized
that you scared you know sometimes feel
how deep you think you got your soul I'm
done my humble time oh here we go again
you want your legacy to be muscle shirts
and body counts do all this you didn't
shoot anybody
come on cab you know how shots yeah [ __ ]
me nice trees I never trusted a Bible II
am asking you man
bad boys one last time one last time but
not just black with cops - we pull
ourselves over later
we will write about the clown I've been
telling you ask we're here he can [ __ ]
Mike
he's in like a speech
bad boys bad what she got it no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you [ __ ] up the lyrics which take a
long time to learn I want you to play a
game with me right I don't want to play
a game oh please no I said playing game
with me right wait ugly I want you to
imagine a character your boss
Mickey piss you're too smart to be
blackmailing us Fletcher hey sweet Mary
Jane is my vice your boys on the other
hand is and always has been the
destroyer of worlds
you're out of touch and I would like you
to consider an offer I am NOT for sale
the plot begins to thicken now I can't
be specific about the heroes and zero
but our protagonist is a hungry animal
you there is a lot of money hanging in
the balance our antagonist explodes on a
seed black a millennial firewall and has
indirectly started a war I think you
need to see this boss
[Music]
they find it make inquiries his name is
[ __ ] we spelled with a pH I was going
for Huck please sorry for her kind of
hawk bills
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire do you get a stamp that out
quickly these people are gonna clean
house and you are part of that house in
the jungle only way a lion survives not
by acting like by be okay
[Music]
it's really warming up now isn't it
from the lines hungry these
[Music]
never associates or not so you killed
someone no it was the gravity that
killed him we need those phones
[Music]
[Music]
and the corner over there you really
ruin in my slow right now you know that
got an issue his movement man
[Music]
we have 15 minutes it's time hit it
[Music]
hello boys
or if I told you I know what happens
when you die
you become a ghost buy more criminal
records
no more office parties rush stupid
weddings
best part of being dead is the freedom
not policies or politics no one touch is
mine we answer to no one you can take
outs and truly evil people
[Music]
these people were declared today none of
us will be remembered it's about to
happen will you think honey raise the
better ones right
for no one
if they exist they can be made not
fighter jets
sorry for yelling welcome to the world's
biggest magnet
[Music]
I'd work I mean I wasn't sure had a
suspicion but I yeah this is awesome
[ __ ] dangerous
still talking to you French it's
complicated many a dear when we first
got together we were different people
[Music]
grandpa hey Anthony this is a Martha and
Bethany mrs. Fisher grandfather's meet
you
morning sort of bargain on you you're
not barking he's barging my little
Walker yeah did you guys see Spencer
Vicki went back in we gotta go get him
huh what who are you oh my god you're
Spencer's grandfather
are we in Florida and you my little
walk-up did I die and turn into some
kind of a small muscular Boy Scout are
we dead it sure feels good now okay you
have some issues here
the game is busted who's the game I'm
not yet I don't wonder yet
welcome to Jumanji
the sniffs vet joke is even more
challenging and remember you child
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji as
that barbers boy we're gonna die we did
are we in hell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the fellas to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity is
this stupid face you make you having a
heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
this will not be a war of heroes
which is all to see this is going to be
fun the world burns you have no idea of
what men are capable of we must do
something I know you want to fight
but there are other ways of doing your
duty you're going to need a suit come on
we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace and
protecting life while governments wait
for orders our people take action now
it's time to
[Music]
captain structure
oh my
[Music]
our enemies think we are gentlemen
but reputation is what people think of
you
character is what you are
all right yes
[Music]
but ready we shall see
this is called a parachute it means that
one can jump out of a plane safely
[Music]
[Applause]
even who's locking a weapon expect a big
pain brother whole body's a weapon sorry
[Music]
kill me
what [ __ ] is that my name is Sarah
Connor I hunt terminators he's the most
lethal Terminator ever created
I'm going to help you protect the girl
so you're Carl that's what everyone
calls me yes I'm never gonna [ __ ]
call you Carl
if we don't win this one
it's all over
you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing
without a master no one gives two shits
who we are beyond that
the Joker and I broke up I wanted a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only daemon got them looking for
emancipation
ocular new screen she lost me
[Applause]
who are you guys
[Music]
you're still
you need
we should order pizzas
[Applause]
[Music]
who's having a good time
you psycho chick could never call a
woman chick I'll accept fraud lady bunny
but on occasion [ __ ] eh move that for
anyway am i dad you're in a coma
you mean this is only dreaming memories
everyone a chemicals to the same common
space
here in a coma some people develop
unique abilities but to discover those
abilities a person need a party
needs to be put in danger now maybe
we'll see what your ability will be
the man from the balcony is he the
leader he taught us how to survive we're
here for a reason everyone was here
didn't make it in reality
they didn't have a future there you
haven't figured out nothing happened
I am the one in charge here
this world is made of memories how did
they get here there's an island for your
Reapers somewhere in the coma we're
always looking for people who can help
us get there
is this my life now I remember that I
couldn't be together with who I wanted
to be
here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you need reality for after that
we need to wake up
you can't wake up do you understand your
body is there in coma
you are sure there's nothing you can do
about it life in coma is as real as it
gets I said hold it
[Music]